[Musique]
Général Norlin, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Comment allez-vous ?
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Oui, mon nom est Bernard
Norlin et euh je suis général d'armée
aérienne, donc de l'armée de l'air et
j'ai été pilote de chasse euh euh toute
ma carrière militaire. J'ai commencé
donc
par l'école de l'air puis par puis j'ai
volé sur tous les mirages, tous les
types de mirage à l'exception du rafal.
Je n'ai pas volé sur rafale et j'ai j'ai
accumulé 6000 heures de vol
au total. Bon, c'est rien pour un pilote
de ligne mais c'est beaucoup à mon avis
pour un pilote de chasse. Voilà. à la
suite du à la suite de quoi
euh j'ai commandé l'aviation de chasse.
À un moment, on a regroupé l'armée de
l'air a regroupé tous ces avions de
chasse dans un même commandement. Donc
j'ai commandé j'ai eu la chance et
l'honneur de commander toute l'aviation
de chasse à la fin de ma carrière de
pilote. Ensuite, j'ai été directeur de
l'Institut des études de défense
nationale. J'ai oublié de dire que quand
j'étais tout jeune général, j'ai été
chef du cabinet militaire de deux
premiers ministres euh Jacques Chirac
puis Michel Rocard de 1986 à 1990
environ.
Et quand j'ai quitté l'armée de l'air,
bon, j'ai ensuite j'ai eu une carrière
un peu un peu dans le civil pendant une
bonne douzaine d'années et maintenant je
suis vice-président d'une organisation
qui s'appelle Initiative pour le
désarmement nucléaire et que nous avons
créé avec Paul Kilè, ancien ministre de
la défense et Jean-Marie Collin qui est
actuellement représentant d'an pour la
France.
Alors, on va parler dissuasion
nucléaire, on va parler terroristes, on
va parler pensée stratégique, on va
parler tout un tas de choses autour de
tout ça.
Merci d'être là ce soir, on est très
content d'avoir un pilote.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
la perception de la pensée stratégique ?
Qu'est-ce qui a au commande ? Qui fait
cette pensée stratégique ? Qui nous
impose une doctrine ?
Écoutez, c'est la réponse est est assez
complexe puisque officiellement il y a
une version officielle
qui veut que la pensée stratégique, elle
est préparée dans les différents
ministères et particulièrement au
ministère de la défense et synthétiser,
si je puis dire, au niveau du
secrétariat général pour la défense
nationale et la sécurité et que ensuite
c'est le président de la République dans
les conseils de défense qui se tiennent
maintenant assez fréquemment avec les
chefs d'étatmajor, avec les différents
responsables, donc les différents
ministres, ministre de la défense,
ministre des affaires étrangères qui
élaborent
cette les concepts stratégiques de la
France, donc la politique de défense de
la France. Bon, ça c'est la version
officielle.
Bon effectivement c'est c'est comme ça
que ça se fait mais entre en jeu un
certain nombre d'experts qui donnent le
qui qui sont consultés plus ou moins
consultés. Il y a des organismes de
réflexion stratégique au sein du
ministère des affaires étrangères, au
sein du ministère d'aller de défense, au
sein des armées. Tout ça euh
mature une réflexion qui se qui se
voudrait qui se veut la politique de
défense de la France. Bon, le problème
et j'ai oublié de dire que tout ça
aboutit à la rédaction d'un livre blanc
qui définit les grands axes de la
politique de défendre. Bon, tout ça est
très bien, mais la réalité euh et je
pense qu'on va on va y revenir un peu
plus tôt, c'est que euh la pensée
stratégique française est figée. Elle
est figée depuis que la dissuasion
nucléaire a été sacralisée, sacrée comme
la clé de voûte de notre défense. Plus
il n'y a plus aucune liberté de
manœuvre. À partir du moment où le quand
le livre blanc est rédigé, il y a une
consigne qui dit "Vous ne touchez pas à
la dissuasion nucléaire.
Et à partir de ce moment-là, bon, il y a
plus d'évolution possible. Il n'y a plus
d'adaptation au contexte. On va on va
reparler de la dissuasion nucléaire sur
la pensée stratégique. Pourquoi elle est
figée ? C'est parce que tout ce globi
boulga de sing tank, un interministériel
avec des gens qui ont été nommés là
parce que c'est le fils de machin. S'il
a fait le machin l'ubid dans telle
école, il est dans la bonne carte, il
est encarté correctement. Ce glou boulga
stratégique,
il est figé pourquoi ? Il est figé parce
que tout ça ou il est figé parce que on
a peur de faire bouger la pensée
stratégique parce qu'on a peur de plus
être adoubé par notre commandant ou la
chaîne de commandement ou
non parce que bon d'une part c'est ce
que vous avez dit c'est que on est un
peu prisonnier de de d'un concept qu'on
ne veut qu'on ne veut pas voir évoluer.
Bon, je reviens. Malheureusement, c'est
la dissuase nucléaire qui qui
fige complètement la pensée stratégique.
Mais il y a aussi d'autres aspects. Ce
qui est l'aspect, c'est le fait qu'on
est lié par des nos accords
internationaux et que en matière de
pensée stratégique, il faut il faut il
faut dire qu'on est complètement à la
remorque des de la pensée stratégique
américaine. Et ça se décline non
seulement dans la pensée stratégique au
sens noble du terme mais aussi dans la
pensée tactique. Si vous regardez le
vocabulaire, le langage, les concepts
les concepts qui sont élaborés dans dans
la conception des opérations et cetera,
vous c'est un copiercollé
de tous les concepts américains. On n
plus aucune pensée au plan
qui soit adapté à notre situation
française ou franco-européenne. On n
plus aucune pensée autonome,
indépendante. On est complètement lié
soit par nos accords, soit par le fait
qu'on est figé dans cette dans ce
concept de dissuasion nucléaire qui doit
rester la clé de voûte de notre système
de défense. Là
là, vous faites référence à la pensée
stratégique américaine. Là actuellement
les Américains font des exercices à la
frontière russe font des exercices de de
bombardement nucléaire en cas d'invasion
russe.
Pour vous, c'est une doctrine qui est
figée ? C'est une doctrine que les
Américains peuvent encore se permettre.
C'est c'est quoi ? ici
bah c'est c'est tout simplement que les
Américains par le biais de l'OTAN
notamment parce que c'est pas le seul
biais bon nous entraînent dans leur
politique de défense à eux en ce moment
ils sont dans dans une situation
d'affrontement avec la Russie
avec la Chine plutôt
avec la Chine bien sûr oui parce que
pour eux euh c'est la Chine qui sera ou
qui est ou qui et qui sera de plus en
plus le l'ennemi privilégié et en plus
les États-Unis adorent les situations
euh simples
Il y a le bon et le méchant
et le marteau et le clou
et le marteau. Il faut toujours un
méchant. Donc la Chine est le méchant
idéal mais il reste quand même la Russie
qui a quand même une capacité nuisante
non négligeable et qui donc reste bon en
particulier pour les pays d'Europe
centrale et les pays baltes l'ennemi
numéro 1. Donc il y a il y a tout un
enchaînement de fête qui nous rend
dépendant des États-Unis, qui nous
entraîne dans des situations
conflictuelles avec la Russie. C'est
pour la raison pour laquelle bon je
pense que le président Macron essaye à
juste titre essaie en ce moment de de se
dégager de de cette de cet enchaînement
conflictuel avec la Russie.
On va revenir à la pensée stratégique.
Comment on fait pour la moderniser ?
Comment on fait pour lui injecter du 109
? Comment on fait pour la faire sortir
de la boîte ?
Ça vous fait marrer ?
Oui. Pour commencer, il faut faire que
vous connaissez le slogan, il faut faire
table rase de ce qui existe avant. Si on
veut se projeter dans l'avenir parce que
c'est ça une politique de défense, c'est
essayer de se projeter dans l'avenir de
manière à assurer la sécurité de de son
pays et de l'Europe face aux menaces du
du futur pour autant qu'on puisse les
prévoir et les les anticip. C'est quoi
pour vous les menaces du futur ? C'est
quoi pour vous les menaces du futur ?
Et bien c'est les menaces qui sont dire
d'abord liées à l'émergence des
nouvelles technologies. C'est le tout ce
qui est cyberattaque, tout ce qui est
lié aussi au développement de
l'intelligence artificielle parce que ça
c'est très important et c'est très bien
connu. C'est lié à l'espace, c'est lié
au dérèglement climatique parce que
c'est le dérèglement climatique sera
inévitablement une source de tension et
de conflit et que donc euh les pays,
tous les pays du monde vont risquent
d'être entraînés dans des dans des dans
cette espèce de de spirale
conflictuelle. toujours voilà donc c'est
cet ensemble et justement c'est la
capacité à anticiper et à essayer de
prévoir quels sont les les menaces du
futur qui qui fait la valeur d'une
politique de différence. On n'y est pas
du tout. Bien sûr on parle de
cyberattaque, bien sûr on parle d'espace
bien sûr on parle un peu un peu
d'intelligence artificielle mais c'est
ça n'est pas le cœur du sujet ça devrait
être le cœur du sujet de notre politique
de défense.
Donc faire table rase ça veut dire quoi
? Ça veut dire virer tout le monde.
Ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire
non, je reviens un peu ma à ma marote.
C'est c'est abandonner l'idée. J'ai pas
dit qu'il fallait jeter toutes les armes
nucléaires tout de suite à la poubelle,
mais abandonner l'idée que la dissuasion
nucléaire est la clé de voûte de notre
politique de défense et la garantie
absolue de notre sécurité et que et
qu'elle est elle est efficace face aux
nouvelles menaces. Il faut abandonner
cette idée et rebâtir un nouveau une
nouvelle politique de défense sur une
analyse plus dégagé de tous ces de
touses ces anciennes scories qui font
qu'on est complètement bloqué dans notre
pensée.
C'est à cause de tous ces soviétologues
réformés. C'est à cause de quoi ? On
fait quoi alors pour dynamiser tous ces
tong ces ministères ?
On commence par leur dire, "Écoutez,
oubliez ce que vous tout ce que vous
faites, toute la pensée. Le le problème,
je vais être peut-être un peu direct,
c'est que tous ces single tank en je
parle en France sont tous dépendants
du gouvern enfin du d'un ministère ou de
plusieurs ministères. Il il n'y en a, je
crois qu'en France, il y en a peut-être
un ou deux, mais tous les grands, il n'y
en a aucun indépendant à l'exception de
peut-être de vous de Comment voulez-vous
avoir une pensée originale, avoir une
pensée qui sort du cadre si vous
dépendez des financements, des budgets
et cetera qui sont délivrés, bon bien
sûr sous condition par tel ou tel
ministère. Donc dès le départ le système
nivicier une une idée peut-être serait
de recréer comme ça se passe un peu
États-Unis où ils sont beaucoup plus
libres dans leur expression dans leur
pensées.
Il faudrait recréer
des des conditions pour pour qu'il y ait
des des symptômes qui soient un peu
indépendants ou garantir leur
indépendance de manière à ce qu'au moins
il y ait une pensée un petit peu
originale qui sorte des clous.
Quand on voit Poutine, la Russie de
Poutine avec ses nouveaux missiles
hypersoniques,
capable d'éviter toute défense aérienne,
capable de voler virtuellement,
indéfiniment, quand on voit un Donald
Trump tweeter d'une façon rageuse dès le
matin, quand on voit un Kim Jun
développer sa bombinette, quand on voit
le Pakistan,
la France, elle se situe où dans ce
glouy boulga ? Elle peut dire voilà on
fait le désarmement
multilatéralement,
elle doit elle doit commencer comment ?
Le le désarmement doit commencer comment
? Bon, d'abord, c'est vrai que
actuellement, il y a une génération de
dirigeants qui est euh qui est
absolument qui est un peu effrayante. Si
vous il y a toute une brochette de
dirigeants qui est qui exploit euh les
sentiments nationalistes de leur
population et qui les exacerb. Donc
c'est une situation hyper dangereuse.
Donc effectivement, c'est pas euh on on
peut dire que c'est pas le moment euh de
des armées et cetera, mais le problème
du euh du nucléaire, on y reviendra
peut-être, est un est un est un cas
particulier. La la France, elle doit
commencer par dire le nucléaire n'est
pas euh la solution et n'est pas per il
n'est pas pertinent pour répondre au
défut des sécurités actuelles. On
commence par regarder les défus de
sécurité et bon on voit bien que quand
il si on regarde ce qui se passe
actuellement dans les conflits qui
soient tels que nous les connaissons
actuell ça part du terrorisme, ça va en
Syrie, ça va en Afghanistan et cetera,
je vous passe l'Irak, l'Iran et cetera.
On voit bien que pour l'instant euh
c'est pas le nucléaire qui a qui a
permis de régler le les problèmes. Quand
vous vous parlez de hacking et de
cyberattaque, on va pas régler ça à coup
de de bombe nucléaire. Quand on voit les
conflits tels qu'ils sont actuellement,
c'estàd conflits asymétriques, des
conflits hybrides, on règle pas ça avec
des armes nucléaires. Donc voilà, il
faut commencer par ça et ensuite il
n'est pas enf pour pour moi et pour et
pour mon organisation, il n'est pas
question de dire on va mettre toutes les
armes nucléaires françaises à la
poubelle tout de suite mais il faut
arrêter parce que le problème c'est
qu'il faut arrêter cette cette
course aux armements nucléaires qui est
telle qu'elle se passe actuellement.
C'est une spirale ascendante qui fait
qu' en ce momentlà on rajoute des
couches et vous savez comment c'est le
c'est la glève et la balance quand vous
avez un armement l' dit moi je veux le
je veux le le meilleur je veux et ainsi
de suite. C'est une échelle c'est une
échelle avec des barreaux dont on ne
redescend pas. Donc il faut il faut
commencer par arrêter ça. Il y a des tas
de propositions qui sont faites et nous
par exemple on fait des propositions sur
comment on peut réduire diminuer les
tensions, diminuer les arsenaux.
diminuer les systèmes d'alerte et cetera
et cetera.
Comment on fait pour diminuer les
tensions ?
Et ben, on commence par la transparence
par être un peu plus transparent. Ça
sera déjà d'ailleurs euh dans le
prochain euh euh conférence de revue du
traité de prolifération. Ça sera un des
grands sujets qui sera évoqué, c'est
comment on améliore la transparence en
dans dans les armements d'une manière
générale, pas seulement dans les
armement nucléaires aussi
biologique
ou et alors biologique alors pour
l'instant on voit ce que ce que ce comm
connaiss comme conséquence pardon le par
exemple le coronavirus c'est c'est
impressionnant comment une simple un
simple virus paralyse va paralyser le
monde entier donc c'est une leçon
justement pour les politiques de défense
future. C'est comment
c'est la mondialisation, c'est le fait
cette globalisation qui fait qui n'a pas
été militarisé, un virus tout à fait
normal.
Oui, c'est ce qu'on dit. Mais
effectivement donc le le jour enfit
d'ailleurs ça s'est déjà produit hein,
c'est déjà le le l'arme biologique,
c'est vieux comme le monde hein. On
empoisonnait déjà les cadavres pour les
jeter chez
les Indiens, on leur donnait des des
couvertures à la varie.
Voilà. et c'est Jean Giscan qui jetait
des cadavres empoisonnés pour dans les
dans les cités qu' qu'il a siégé. Donc
voilà, il y a il y a il y a beaucoup de
mesures qui qui permettent de de essayer
de réduire les tensures. Le problème
c'est ça, c'est qu'on est en ce moment
dans une spirale euh euh ascendante euh
en matière de course aux armements, de
tension de de de tension croissantes.
Alors, je vais me faire l'avoquer du
diable parce que là quand je vous
écoute, avec tout le respect que je me
dois, mon général, j'ai l'impression
d'entendre un vieux IPI.
Alors, je je me fais je me fais l'avocat
du diable.
On est dans un système hypertendu,
overstetch comme nous nous disent nos
amis américains.
Tension sur les ressources, tension
démographique, tension avec le le
climat, tension sur tout un tas de
choses, l'eau, sur la pollution et tout
un tas de choses comme ça, sur
l'économie, la guerre économique est à
son paroxisme.
On va détendre tout ça comment ? Parce
que ça m'a l'air un peu du wishful
sinking ce que vous me faites là. Parce
que si je prends par exemple Kim Jung,
je fais comment pour le détendre ? Par
exemple, si je prends Donald Trump, je
fais comment pour le détendre ?
Vaste programme.
Non, pas du tout. Le le problème, c'est
que on en revient ou on en vient à
l'arme nucléaire, c'est que au bout du
bout avec des armes nucléaires, c'est
que le conflit nucléaire. Bon, c'est ça
la question.
Rappelez le dégât que peut faire une
bombe par exemple de de 15 m.
de 15 mégaton. Il y en a on en fait plus
mais on détruit une New York
complètement. Mais on estime par exemple
que dans le cas d'un conflit limité
entre l'Inde et Pakistan, je dis bien un
conflit limité euh c'est 20 millions de
20 millions de morts tout de suite. Bon
alors ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut bien
rappeler dont on doit se souvenir c'est
que il y a pas simplement les morts à
l'instant t l'instant de l'explosion il
y a aussi toutes les les morts du fait
des radi de la radioactivité
du fait des cancers qui vont et ça sur
plusieurs générations. des organisations
de l'État, des organisations des
l'impact sur le climat, vous savez ce
qu'on c'est ce qu'on appelle l'hiver
nucléaire, c'estàdire que l'émission de
nuages radioactif obscurcit le soleil et
le problème c'est que ces ces nuages
radioactifs vont obscurcir vont avoir un
impact sur la planète entière avec les
courants et cetera. Et donc il y a des
calculs très scientifiques qui ont été
faits et qui montrent qu'il y a un
impact il y a ensuite il y a un impact
sur la la santé des populations dans le
monde entier. Donc pour en revenir à
votre question, c'est ça le problème,
c'est que le on ne peut pas se permettre
d'avoir un conflit nucléaire. Or, on est
en train
de on est en train d'aller vers un
conflit nucléaire. Alors, je dis pas
qu'il est inévitable bien entendu, mais
je pense que euh je pense que petit à
petit, on se rapproche d'un conflit
nucléaire dans très dangereusement et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
essayer de stopper ça. Mais je ne dis
pas
qu'il faut abandonner tout esprit de
défense et renoncer. Euh au contraire,
mais ce que je dis c'est que il faut euh
repenser notre politique de défense hors
du cas hors du cadre nucléaire ou tout
au moins avec un cadre nucléaire qui qui
va encore durer parce que effectivement
si on pense des armements nucléaires et
si un jour il y a quelqu'un qui dit on
va désarmer ça va prendre 20 ans et
c'est comme ça qu'on aura Kimjung 1 ou
et donc ou même train parce qu'ils
seront pas éternels. et qu'il y aura
forcément un moment si on s'engage dans
cette voie où bon quand même on va
réaliser que petit à petit on arrive à
arrive à
désarmer je parle nucléairement à la
suite de ensuite de quoi il faut
effectivement que au plan de la défense
on ait cette politique qui soit nouvelle
mais je ne veux je ne dis absolument pas
qu'il faille complètement désarmer et
cetera et cetera beaucoup le pensent
hein je le disent effectivement Mais
bon, c'est pour l'instant ça me paraît
assez réaliste.
Quand vous voyez l'Allemagne qui l'orgne
sur le la défense nucléaire française
qui souhaiterait se mettre sous le
parapluie nucléaire français, ça vous
fait quoi ? Alors euh premièrement euh
je ne pense pas que l'Allemagne l'orgne.
Peut-être que euh je pense que c'est un
un ministre de la CDU
qui a dit qui euh ça serait peut-être
pas mal mais bon moi je bon et ça mais
ça ne correspond absolument pas à ce que
pensent les Allemands hein.
Cela dit, pour rectifier, pour corriger
un tout petit peu ce que je dis, je ne
sais pas si tout le monde se rappelle,
se souvient que
les armes nucléaires tactiques
américaines sont armées sur des avions
allemands et ce sont des pilotes
allemands qui emmènent qui emmèneraient
ces bombes nucléaires tactiques. Donc il
y a quand même déjà du nucléaire en
Allemagne sous contrôle américain mais
bon ça existe quand même.
Ce que vous appelez nucléaire tactique,
c'est des ogives qui font combien de
tonnes ou de mégatonnes.
Ah non, c'est pas des alors méga alors
l'échelle Hiroshima, c'est 15 kn
actuellement. Euh alors on a dans les
années 60 on a avec la bombe à
hydrogène, on a il y a eu une espèce de
course à la puissance nucléaire et donc
il y a eu la tsarbomba
soviétique qui faisait je crois autour
de 15 mn. Donc c'est donc vous voyez 15
c'est un peu plus que 15 m je pense pour
la de Sarbon quoi.
Ouais. Donc donc c'est maintenant on est
on a abandonné cette course à la
puissance et on est revenu à des à des
charges nucléaires qui tourne en moyenne
autour de 150 kn par exemple sur un un
missile les missiles et les oliives
nucléaires qui équipent nos missiles
dans sur nos sous-marins en gros 150 kn
mais c'est ajustable on peut diminuer on
peut augmenter et bon on y reviendra
peut-être aussi mais maintenant la
tendance c'est à diminuer donc avoir des
plus petits petite charge
faire des des frappes nucléaires
chirurgicales, c'est ça ?
Voilà. Phase. Ouais. Ça peut se dire ça.
Une frappe chirurgicale nucléaire, une
frappe préventive chirurgicale
nucléaire. C'est pas encore une fois
prendre le contrôleur dialectique pour
dire "Vous inquiétez pas, ce sera".
Exactement. Voilà. On essaie de vendre
au public, au grand public l'idée que
après tout
une petite charge et surtout maintenant
ce qui a parce que des petites charges
ont s'en faire depuis très longtemps
pendant la guerre froide, les forces de
l'OTAN avaient des obus de mortiers
nucléaires. Il y avait des missiles R
RR, donc des petits missiles qui étaient
nucléaires. Donc il y avait des grenades
nucléaires dans les sous-marins. Donc il
y avait donc on savait miniaturiser mais
ce qu'on ne savait pas faire et ce qui a
été une vraie révolution hein, c'était à
la base de la révolution dans les
affaires militaires des années 80 90
américaines, c'est la précision,
c'est la capacité de mettre un missile
dans une bouche d'aération dans un dans
une fenêtre avec une grande précision.
Donc on pourra en revenir avec ça. Ça,
il y a beaucoup de ça a ça a beaucoup de
conséquences en terme de renseignement
parce que si vous voulez mettre un
missile dans une fenêtre ou dans une
bouche d'oration, encore faut-il que
vous sachiez identifier. Donc ça veut
dire que vous l'immeuble vous devez le
connaître par cœur. Vous devez connaître
tout l'environnement. Il faut avoir il y
a tout un il y a toute une bibliothèque
de d'information euh numérisé bien
entendu qui qui est absolument
indispensable. Je vous une parenthèse
qui n'a rien à voir avec la dissuasion
nucléaire. Vous en tant que que général
5 étoiles dans l'armée de l'air, c'est
il y a pas un grade au-dessus. L'affaire
Snowdon, l'affaire Juliene, les lanceurs
d'alerte dans l'armée, Bradley Maning,
Chelsea Manning, ça vous fait quoi ?
Vous êtes pour ? Vous êtes contre ? Vous
trouvez ça bien ? Vous trouvez ça pas
bien ? C'estàd
le
sur le sur le principe, moi je trouve ça
plutôt bien. Je pense que c'est bien
parce que il y a quand même bon c'est
pas nouveau hein, une tendance des
gouvernements à à cacher les choses.
Donc sur le principe c'est bien le
problème c'est quand ça met en jeu la
vie la vie des militaires ou des agents
de renseignement ou des services
spéciaux. Voilà, là ça pose là ça pose
un problème éthique et je c'est je suis
pas sûr que que ça soit fait toujours
dans cet esprit-là.
Il y a il y a il y a pas eu de dommages
collatéraux
pas que je sache. Donc moi sur le
principe je suis je suis plutôt pour. Je
pense que il y a trop, on cache trop de
choses. Euh et donc il faut aussi qu'il
y ait une information parce que
maintenant il faut qu'il y ait une
information. C'est c'est vrai pour dans
tous les domaines et en particulier dans
le domaine des armements et en
particulier dans le deè domaine des
armements nucléaires.
Je vais vous reposer une une autre
question un peu plus personnelle
histoire de vous déconcentrer un peu.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà tué
d'abord en tant que aviateur et pilote
de chat ? On voit pas
et franchement non. Non, franchement
non.
Non, je pense pas non.
Donc non, parce que moi l'essentiel de
ma carrière s'est passé pendant la
guerre froide.
Donc la guerre froide, bon c'est on
faisait un métier dangereux hein, un
métier de pilote de chasse un métier
dangereux mais quand même on tournait
beaucoup en rond entre le long du rideau
de fer et dans le l'est de la France.
Donc il n'y a que dans les années 80 où
là il y a eu toutes les opérations en
Afrique où là on on s'est retrouvé
beaucoup plus engagé sur des vrais
théâtres d'opération.
Vous avez donné
vous avez donné un ordre létal à vos
pilotes à votre à votre chasse ?
Ah bah oui, à partir du moment où vous
mettez des bombes sur les avions et que
vous leur dites de partir pour Oui, bien
sûr.
Qu'est-ce que ça fait ça ? On arrive à
dormir ? La psychologie de du chef
d'étatmajor c'est quoi ?
Bon, j'étais pas chef d'étatmajor mais
j'étais patron de l'aviation de chasse.
Oui. Euh bien sûr qu'il y a des
responsations
préparées, les objectifs sont connus.
Euh les missions, les objectifs de de
non seulement de des missions, mais de
la guerre sont connus. Voilà. Bon, mais
c'est le job, hein.
Donc donc
je pense qu'il y a pas de d'hésitation.
Il y a des hésitations si effectivement
vous trouvez dans des conditions très
particulières.
Un ordre donné doit être exécuté sans
être discuté. C'est ça.
Alors, vous savez que le règlement
militaire a changé sur ce point-là. On a
le droit dans certaines conditions de
désobéir. C'est
les bayonnettes intelligentes. C'est ça.
Référence au général de Gaulle.
Vos penseurs militaires, vos auteurs
de pensées stratégiques, c'est lesquels
? C'est plutôt Carl von Closville, c'est
quoi ? Bon, on est tous on est tous
nourris euh bien sûr un peu de clos. Moi
bon d'abord c'est deux goa hein qui moi
pour moi c'est enfin pour la France et
puis même pour la pensée stratégique
c'est c'est ça a été vraiment et c'est
encore maintenant le notre penseur hein
stratégique. Alors après ça vous
déclinez
il y a des gens comme Lidlart
il y a des anglais beaucoup et des
Américains.
George Kinan. Euh vous avez et puis en
France vous avez les quatre cavaliers de
l'apocalypse qui ont été les gr les
quatre quatre généraux d'ailleurs qui
ont été les penseurs de de la dissuasion
nucléaire française, c'est-à-dire le
général Galois,
le général
Poirier, le général Poirier, le général
je me rappelle plus enfin, ils sont
quatre hein. Et donc ces quatre là, bon
parmi eux, il y a vraiment Poirier qui a
été le concepteur de la dissuasion
nucléaire. Mais je pense que plus
récemment,
il y a quelqu'un qui n'était pas un
général et qui qui est mort il y a pas
très longtemps qui s'appelle Pierre
Asner et qui je pense qu' était un très
très grand penseur.
Feu Pierre Asner,
un tout petit bonhomme.
Ouais, absolument. et qui était un type
formidable. Et je bon, il a pas il a pas
écrit beaucoup de livres, c'est plutôt
euh c'est plutôt des recueils d'articles
de réflexion mais c'est c'est je pense
que c'est été celui qui a été le plus
loin dans la réflexion stratégique du
côté français. J'aimais beaucoup Raymond
Aron aussi. Raymon Aron. Voilà. Donc,
mais bon, il y en a il y en a d'autres
que j'oublie bien sûr.
Une pensée chaleureuse pour Pierre
Asner.
Ouais.
Qui qui euh
qui qui était qu' aurait mérité d'être
entouré un peu plus pendant la
Oui, le pauvre, il a ouis il a été assez
méconnu. H
euh, on va revenir à la dissuasion
nucléaire. Quand on voit un kim Junoun
développer son missile balistique, sa
bombinette et que les médias nous nous
servent ça comme il va frapper le Japon,
il va frapper la Corée du Sud, est-ce
que vous pensez pas qu'il a développé ce
cette dissuasion pour aller taper les
satellites juste au-dessus de chez lui
et créer ce que ce qu'avaient créé les
Américains par inadvertance en 1960 ou
67 ? C'était Starfish, le raté américain
où ils ont fait péter une bombinette à
la frontière de l'espace. Ça avait cramé
l'ensemble de tous les satellite. Il en
avait 27 à l'époque, je crois bien.
Là, j'ai pas beaucoup de
souvenirs ni d'information sur cet
aspect, mais je Écoutez Kim Jangin
comme vous voudrez. Bon, c'est c'est
assez clair. Il veut exister,
il veut euh résister et il veut
survivre.
Un peu comme Israël, non ? Oui. Oui, un
peu. Et c'est et il faut il y a quand
même que dans l'affaire qui Corée du
Nord, il y a quand même plusieurs
aspects qui sont intéressants. C'est un
c'est le fait qu'un pays euh pauvre
comme le Pakistan, d'ailleurs,
relativement pauvre quand même euh bon
entouré de blocus, entouré d'ennemis,
réussi à développer un armement
nucléaire. le Pakistan l'avait fait
avant lui et réussi à s'imposer comme
état nucléaire
euh
bon sans que au fond enfin c'est pas que
sans que personne ne trouve à y redire
puisque là les Américains soup
intéressés bien entendu mais sans que au
fond ça choque vraiment mais c'est si on
regarde c'est un peu c'est comme l'Iran
c'estàd c'est le fait que l'Iran tout le
monde hurle après l'Ir mais l'Iran ne
fait que euh l'Iran, c'est notre enfant
si au plan nucléaire, si je puis dire,
pourquoi
tous ces pays
veulent se doter de l'arme nucléaire
parce qu'ils sont victimes de notre
discours.
Le club des cinq des cinq états
nucléaires qui sont dit dotés,
les États-Unis, la Russie, la Chine, la
Grande-Bretagne et la France, qu'est-ce
qu'elles disent ? Nous assurons notre
sécurité grâce à la bombe grâce aux
armes nucléaires. Pourquoi voulez-vous ?
Alors, tant que c'était un monde
bipolaire,
ça marchait. Bon, il y avait deux pôles.
Donc, les Russie, les USA aventurs armes
nucléaires. Très bien. Tout le monde
était content. Mais quand il s'agit
d'un monde multipolaire où il y a de des
tas de pays qui émergent, pourquoi
voulez-vous qu'un pays comme l'Iran et
même des petits pays comme la Corée du
Nord ne se dotent pas de de leur propre
arme nucléaire ? Donc c'est exactement
la conséquence directe de notre
discours. C'est-à-dire que euh tout en
disant qu'on est contre la
prolifération, on a un discours de
proliférant et c'est ça le très grand
danger de de notre comportement.
parce que jusqu'à maintenant, on a
toujours eu grâce au TNP le droit
TNP
traité traité de non prolifération.
Alors signé en 1970,
bon c'était en gros une entente entre
les grands pays nucléaires pour empêcher
justement que d'autres pays se dotent de
l'alarme nucléaire. La France ne l'a
ratif signé ratifié que qu'en 1992 quand
même beaucoup plus tard. Bon, c'est le
traité de non prolifération, c'est un un
deal, c'est un marché.
D'un côté, vous avez les les cinq pays
nucléaires qui avaient des armes
nucléaires depuis les années 60, donc
avant le traité de non prolifération
auquel on leur a dit, les autres pays de
l'ONU leur ont dit "OK, vous avez le
droit de les garder pour l'instant."
Nous ce qu'on demande c'est un la
capacité de développer un armement
nucléaire pardon une énergie nucléaire
civile.
Mais en revanche vous, d'accord, on vous
donne le droit mais c'est un droit
provisoire. Vous devez vous engager à
éliminer les armes nucléaires dans dans
un délai. Alors, c'est là où le
c'était éliminer les missiles, pas les
charges, les
d'éliminer les armements, je dis je
répète les armements nucléaires.
Donc
là où c'est pas clair, c'est que c'était
de bonne foi. Bon ça mais c'est
l'article 6 du traité non prolifération.
Ça veut dire que les cinq pays
nucléaires, ce que l'on a ce qu'on
appelle les états nucléaires dotés
ont pris l'engagement formel devant les
autres pays des tous les autres pays
puisque le TNP a été signé je crois par
194 pays. Donc à peu près la totalité
des pays, il y en a il y en a que trois
il y en a que quatre ou cin qui ont pas
signé. Donc ont pris l'engagement et cet
engagement, ils ne veulent pas le
respecter. Donc comment voulez-vous que
de que que devant euh que dans cet état
de fait les autres pays euh disent après
tout nous aussi pourquoi nous on a'urait
pas le droit de développer nos armements
nucléaires et tout. Donc on a un
discours et un comportement extrêmement
proliférent alors qu'on a un discours
hyper hypocrite en disant que pas du
tout. Nous, on est contre la
prolifération et cetera et cetera et on
a la main sur le cœur. Donc c'est c'est
un comp c'est une attitude, un discours,
un comportement qui est extrêmement
pervers.
Est-ce que vous croyez une question
internet, est-ce que vous croyez au
nucléaire terroriste ?
Oui.
Alors oui, oui, bien sûr, mais c'est
vrai que jusqu'à maintenant euh il y a
pas eu de cas avéré, mais il y a eu,
vous le savez sûrement, beaucoup de
tentatives de tentatives et il y a eu
des vols de matière ficile, il y a eu
des tentatives, je sais pas si vous vous
rappelez de la secta au Japon.
Bon, eux, ils ont fait une attaque
chimique mais en fait ils cherchaient,
c'est une secte extrêmement puissante et
qui cherche qui avait des ramifications
dans le monde entier et qui a cherché à
se doter d'armes d'armes nucléaires.
Alors, même si c'était ce qu'on appelle
une bombe sale, c'est-à-dire même un un
explosif conventionnel entouré de
matière ficile, même si c'était ça, bon
à chercher. Il y a eu beaucoup de
beaucoup de tentatives et d'essais et
c'était d'ailleurs
Al-Qaïda
avait avait comme objectif de se doter
d'armes nucléaires.
Il y a pas eu des une machine pour
radiographier le bitume qui a été piqué
parce qu'à l'intérieur il y a une masse.
Si si si bien sûr, il y a eu énormément
Il y a eu alors je sais plus mais il y a
eu plusieurs centaines de vols de
matière ficile qui ont été répertoriés.
Donc il y en a eu certainement d'autres
mais c'est vrai que pour l'instant on n
pas eu on n pas de cas avéré de mise en
œuvre par un groupe terroriste de de
d'un tel armement.
Est-ce que à votre époque l'armée se
prépara ce type de risque ? Est-ce que
le l'armée avait par exemple anticipé
des exercices comme une canette de de
matière ficile qui se faisait péter en
haut d'un building et ça vous voyez ce
que je veux dire ?
Oui mais en fait c'est tout le monde se
prépare se prépare ou s'est préparé.
D'abord, il y a eu un un renforcement
des contrôles et puis vous savez que il
y a eu un programme américain et
d'ailleurs pas seulement américain, la
France y a participé à la chute de de
l'Union soviétique pour empêcher donc
aider les soviétiques à reconfigurer
leur matière ficile et à empêcher comme
ça les la dissémination
commerciale entre guillemets de ces
matéri qui qui traînait un peu partout
en R en Union soviétique. Donc il y a
c'est un mais c'est ça implique tout le
monde. Tout le monde est concerné dans
tout dans tous les pays. Tous les
ministères sont concernés que ce soit
les services spéciaux, les ministères de
l'intérieur, tout le monde se lutte
contre ça. Et effectivement de toutes
les manières, il y a les armées, elles
sont pr se préparent et sont préparées à
à une attaque nucléaire. Donc il y a des
toutes les procédures de décontamination
des bunkers, des protections des et
cetera. Il y a tout un système de
procédure extrêmement complexe, hein.
Je vous repose une autre question pour
vous déconcentrer.
Vous avez confiance dans nos politiques
? Vous avez confiance à leur capacité de
de détenir le feu nucléaire ? Est-ce que
vous avez euh
Ça vous fait marrer ?
Écoutez,
c'est Paul Kill disait que c'est des
enfants qui jouent.
Oui. Oui. Parce que souvent
en
ça dépend quel niveau vous vous placez.
Si vous si vous vous placez au niveau du
président de la République, je pense
quand même qu'il est conscient hein
puisque c'est c'est
pour la pour un pour la France
et pour le la 5e République,
le fait que le président détienne la
foudre,
c'est une espèce de d'onction.
présidentiel. C'est-à-dire que c'est ce
qui lui donne euh
ce que je ne crois pas du tout hein,
c'est qui lui donne son autorité, son
voyez quelque chose d'un peu d'un peu
mystique hein. C'est Zeus avec la
foudre. Il y a un côté un peu on y
reviendra aussi peut-être un côté
religieux, un côté mystique dans de dans
de dans tout toute cette affaire
nucléaire. Donc donc je pense que le
président de la République vous rappelez
certainement que Valérie Giscardin avait
dit que s'il avait dû utiliser la l'arme
nucléaire, bon il aurait hésité.
Donc il il a dit expressément et je
pense que tous les présidents et là on
peut citer aussi des présidents de la
République des président pardon
américain tous les présidents ont dit
bon c'est une responsabilité terrible
donc on sait pas et je pense eux-mêmes
ne savent pas si il le s'il le ferait
d'appuyer sur le bouton parce que après
tout bon c'est quand même
l'anéantissement
Quand il s'agit de des pays qui ont des
des armes nucléaires en grand nombre, il
s'agit de l'anéantissement de leur
population. C'est c'est un un des vrais
sujet aussi dans de dans l'armement
nucléaire, c'est le fait que c'est la
vie de millions euh de personnes
qu'on engage sans leur demander leur
avis. On demande jamais la vie des gens.
Donc c'est c'est tout le toute la
question du consensus français de toute
la mystique française autour de la de la
religion du nucléaire. Donc pour revenir
à votre question, le bon je pense que
quand même le président de la
République, bon voilà, il réfléchit
après ça en dessous quand vous discutez
avec des représentants
des représentants élus, bon quelquefois
vous êtes faré par le degré de
méconnaissance
de ces questions
de stupidité.
On peut pas, je sais pas, on peut pas
dire ça, c'est il y a peut-être aussi de
la stupidité mais c'est de
méconnaissance de méconnaissance des de
ces sujets qui sont quand même des
sujets importants.
C'est qui sont amenés à légiférer mais
ils connaissent pas du tout le problème.
Je Ils connaissent pas ou pas du tout.
Oui, ils connaissent souvent, ils
connaissent mal. En tout cas, ils
connaissent mal et puis il leurs
intérêts se réduisent
à l'entreprise machin qui est dans leur
département ou dans leur et cetera dans
leur circonscription.
C'est pour ça qu'il vote t tous les ans
ou tous les 5 ans euh la modernisation
de l'arsenal, la modernisation.
Alors oui, mais ça va plus loin puisque
autour de ça, il y a ce qu'on a pas
encore évoqué, c'est le toute et c'est
surtout vrai en France. C'est peut-être
en France où c'est le plus fort. C'est
tout le la mystique, la religion autour
du nucléaire.
Le alors je parle pas du nucléaire civil
qui fait déjà un peu partie mais le
nucléaire militaire ça fait partie de ce
qu'on appelle maintenant vous savez le
roman national.
C'est intégré dans l'esprit de tout le
monde et en particulier des
représentants de nos représentants le
fait que l'arme nucléaire bon ben c'est
c'est c'est
notre symbole de puissance. C'est un
symbole, c'est un mythe de puissance qui
fait que la France est un grand pays
parce pourquoi elle est un grand pays ?
Parce qu'elle a l'arme nucléaire. Et il
y a même un ancien ministre de la
défense que je ne nommerai pas qui a dit
la bombe c'est la France ou la France
c'est la bombe comme vous voulez. Donc
c'est quand même assez hallucinant.
C'estàd que bon dans l'esprit de cet
homme c'est que si vous êtes contre la
bombe vous êtes contre la France. un
hérétique.
Un hérétique. Et il y a et si vous
regardez bien, il y a tout un
vocabulaire de la religion. Il y a les
excommuniers, il y a les texte sacré, il
y a c'est tout. C'est un hôtel devant
lequel chaque président de la République
vient une fois dans son quinquena se
prosterner
et tout le monde est content et tout les
tous les fidèles applaudissent et aussi
se se prosterne. Donc il y a vraiment
cette dimension qui va bien au-delà du
fait que il faut être réaliste. L'arme
nucléaire, c'est une bombe, enfin une
bombe ou un missile ou tout ce que vous
voudrez, mais c'est un c'est c'est quel
c'est une un objet un objet destructeur,
mais c'est un objet
comment
un gadget
une sorte de gadget et bon un gadget que
on se fait plaisir parce que ça donne un
sentiment de puissance extraordinaire et
c'est vrai, c'est c'est particulièrement
vrai en France mais c'est vrai dans tous
les pays. regarder les débordements de
joie euh de en Inde quand l'Inde a fait
exploser sa première bombe atomique, on
sais plus quelle année, c'était des des
millions d'indiens dans la rue pour
célébrer cet événement extraordinaire.
L'Inde devenait une grande puissance.
C'est ça, c'est ça le problème
nucléaire, c'est que c'est au au plan
militaire, au plan tactique, au plan
stratégique. Bon,
je suis pas le je ne suis pas le seul.
Beaucoup de d'experts entre guillemets
de spécialistes disent que bon euh
l'arme nucléaire c'est pas ça qui va
régler nos problèmes, mais c'est le
symbole de puissance et c'est pour ça
queon y est très très attaché.
Est-ce que vous avez suivi la feral stom
?
Oui, un peu. Hm.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire ?
Euh,
bon, je peux vous en dire ce que peut
pouvant dire un lecteur de journaux
lambda. Euh c'est-à-dire que s'il y a
une une emprise une emprise américaine,
une dépendance américaine absolument euh
excessive euh et et c'est
particulièrement visible euh sous l'air
Trump, dans l'air Trump.
Euh c'est là où on se rend compte qu'on
est complètement dépendant des
Américains, qu'on est complètement lié
aux intérêts américain et que
et qu'on n pas de moyens pour l'instant,
on s'est pas donné les moyens de de se
sortir de cette de cette de cette de
cette dépendance. On est vraiment des
supplétifs des des Américains dans tous
les domaines.
Question d'internet que je vais
reformuler un peu. Euh
les drones, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
? Les drones à grande échelle. Est-ce
que le pilote de chasse est pas déjà
périmé ?
Ah oui, le Non, périmé sûrement pas. Euh
c'est on dit toujours il y aura toujours
des pilotes de chasse. C'est en fait
derrière ce derrière cette question euh
provocatrice, il y a tout le l' tout
l'aspect euh robot, hein. Donc tout
actuellement le discours de pour
l'instant ce qui c'est parfaitement
vrai, c'estàd que bon, les drones c'est
formidable. On en fait, on en a l'usage
de plus en plus, ça va être généralisé
mais il y a derrière ça, il y a le il y
a l'homme et en cas de des drones, c'est
souvent le pilote de chasse. En ce
moment, vous savez que le grand projet
Scaf qui est actuellement qui était le
projet de futur avion de chasse avion de
combat européen, en fait c'est pas un
avion, c'est un ensemble, c'est un
système un système de système, on adore
cette expression où il y a des essins de
drones
qui seront dirigés par un avion piloté.
Donc il y aura toujours un pilote. Il y
en aura peut-être sans doute moins ou
mais il y aura toujours des pilotes.
Mais le derrière tout ça, c'est toute le
toute la question de l'autonomie. euh
des robots et donc toute la question de
l'intelligence artificielle. C'est ça la
vraie question et et je pense que c'est
une vraie question. Euh en ce moment,
les discours euh sont extrêmement
rassurants. C'est vrai que pour
l'instant,
bon voilà, on euh le robot n'est
l'autonomie parce que l'autonomie ça
veut dire une capacité de décision
autonome. Donc pour l'instant, c'est le
cerveau humain quoi. Donc pour
l'instant, on n' pas réussi à faire des
cerveaux humains artificiels robotisés.
Mais ce qui ce qu'on a déjà maintenant
et ce qu'on aura de plus en plus, ce
sont des robots ou des drones par
exemple qui auront une autonomie de
d'ouverture du feu dans certaines
conditions. Alors bien sûr, les
conditions seront déterminées au départ
dans des algorithmes fabriqués et conçus
par des êtres humains, hein, par des
spécialistes.
Mais une fois en l'air, bon le le le
drone, bon, il pourra ouvrir le feu dans
le créneau. Et bon, vous savez bien
queon prévoit jamais tous les cas de
figure et que donc c'est une vraie
question. Alors, il y a beaucoup quand
même des réflexions qui sont faites. Je
crois que le ministère de la défense et
la ministre de la défense a lancé un une
grande réflexion sur ce sujet. Donc
c'est c'est vra je pense qu'il faut
vraiment
il va falloir mettre des gardes fous.
Bon, ça tout le monde est d'accord. Le
problème c'est bon si on met des gardes
fous tout seul c'est pas la peine. Ça ne
servira à rien. Le problème c'est
d'arriver d'arriver à à essayer d'avoir
des règles qui soient admises
sinon par tout le monde mais au moins
par la majorité par la majorité des
pays. Et ça c'est ça ça devient
compliqué et on rentre dans un autre
système qui est le problème des
régulations. Mais c'est un autre
question. Vous voulez qu'on aborde la
régulation ou
si vous voulez ? Oui oui oui. Bah le
c'est-à-dire que vous le savez mieux que
moi, on est dans un monde si je peux si
je peux utiliser une totologie une monde
un monde mondialisé
c'estàd qu'on est tous dépendants et
donc on voit bien que les solutions euh
au grands problèmes que nous avons, je
prends l'exemple du climat, on a fait le
la COP 21, on la respecte, on la
respecte pas l'objectif. On a fait
qu'est-ce que c'est que la COP 21 ?
quand même une tentative de régulation
mondiale des effets d'émission de gaz
carbonique. Regardez le le coronavirus,
on est en train de de mettre en place
des régulations mondiales. Il y a
l'office mondial de la santé qui est là
qui dit il va falloir faire comme c
comme ça. Donc on est maintenant si on
regarde les problèmes de bioéthique
sur la sur la procréation sur les
différents types de procréation la
fabrication de de de clones humains, il
va falloir un jour mettre en place des
régulations mondialisées.
Si on regarde la bourse sur les
finances, on essaie de mettre en place
des régulations. Donc on va de plus en
plus vers des systèmes de régulation. et
cela on y est pas encore
et donc ça sera très difficile à mettre
en place mais je pense que
inévitablement on le fera.
Question internet. Est-ce que la France
a les moyens de détruire un missile
intercontinental ?
Non non non non mais c'était j'allais
dire c'était voulu. C'est c'est c'est
pas voulu. Bon, d'abord techniquement
c'est très difficile. Vous savez que les
Américains avec leur espèce défense,
avec leur défense euh de l'espace, bon
ils sont encore loin du compte, même
s'ils ont mis en place les premières
briques de ce de cette défense. Mais
c'est voulu parce que c'était aussi le
fait de dire que
c'était d'ailleurs un accord, vous savez
c'était l'accord entre les Américains et
les Russes
qui te dire on ne développe pas de
défense antimissile parce que la
vulnérabilité notre vulnérabilité
acceptée de deux côtés est un gage
d'équilibre.
Bon alors c'est pour ça que les Russes
sont furieux parce que les Américains
développant leur capacité d'interception
de missile interconé, ils sont en train
de rompre cet équilibre. Et donc les
Russes disent "Attendez là,
si on n plus nous une capacité de
rétorsion
en particulier nucléaire, bon donc on
devient complètement vulnérable." Donc
c'est pas ils disent c'est pas du tout
comme ça. Nous donc on va développer
nous des armements offensifs. C'est ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire et on est
rentré làdedans dans dans ce jeu. Alors
les Américains ont beau dire "Ah oui
mais bon c'est pas contre vous, c'est
contre l'Iran, mais ça ça n'abuse
personne bien sûr." Donc
ça marche à la télé, non ?
Oui oui oui oui oui oui. Peut-être.
Alors donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
la France jusqu'à d'abord on n pas les
moyens c'est c'est des centaines de
milliards c'est des investissements
colossaux on n pas les moyens
on est devenu une puissance de moyenne
impuissance
manière de voir de de voir le verre à
moitié plein ou à moitié vide. Bon,
c'est vrai qu'on est on est devenu une
moyenne puissance, mais je pense que
bon, d'abord, il faut en prendre
conscience et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a une solution, c'est
mais qui est pas facile à mettre en
œuvre, c'est l'Europe. C'est c'est que
grâce à l'Europe qu'on pourra essayer de
de jouer un rôle et de surtout de
conserver notre notre liberté, notre
liberté. Et voilà. Donc c'est ça, c'est
ça l'enjeu véritable. Donc on ne pourra
pas on ne sortira pas de de de entre
guillemets je crois pas du tout au
déclin mais de ce déclin relatif que que
en envisageant une Europe qui soit plus
unie, plus efficace et cetera, tout tout
ce que tout ce que tout ce que l'on
connaît en matière de de développement
de l'autonomie stratégique en
particulier de l'Europe. Et qu'est-ce
que c'est que l'Europe puissance exact
et cetera ?
C'est c'est un peu de la douce musique
ça vend bien mais on en est vraiment pas
là non ? la défense européenne
alors moi je suis pas je suis pas du
tout le monde en général tout le monde
ricane
quand on parle de défense européenne
d'armée européenne tout le monde soupire
en disant attendez on y arrivera jamais
c'est pas possible on s on n'est pas
capable de s'entendre sur le budget de
la pâqu alors comment voulez-vous qu'on
s'entende sur le budget de sur le budget
des défenses et sur une armée et la
constitution des armées européennes mais
moi je dis d'abord bon il est pas
nécessaire d'espérer pour entreprendre
he il faut entreprendre et C'est doit
être notre objectif. Bien sûr que pour
l'instant on y est pas, mais pourquoi on
y on y serait pas dans quelques années ?
Donc il faut y aller. C'est vraiment la
direction dans laquelle il faut aller.
Et en plus tout le monde tout le monde
sourit quand on parle d'armée
européenne. Mais l'armée européenne elle
existe, elle est là, elle est déjà là.
Il faut pas chercher bien loin. C'est
l'OTAN.
L'OTAN, c'est une machine militaire
formidable qui réussit à rassembler tous
les pays européens. Tous les pays
européens.
même ceux qui sont pas dans l'Union
européenne
autour dans une armée où il y a des
normes depuis que l'OTAN existe, elle a
pondu des c'est une énorme machine
administrative machine à pondre des
normes mais les normes c'est c'est
vraiment le secret de la réussite qui
pond des normes, qui pont des procédures
qui pond des et donc elle est là le
problème c'est que c'est l'armée des
États-Unis. Cette armée, elle est pas
européenne, elle est au service des
États-Unis, des intérêts des États-Unis.
Donc l'idée alors c'est de alors langage
officiel, on va développer un pilier
européen au sein de l'OTAN mais je pense
qu'il faut aller plus loin. Il faut
européaniser l'OTAN c'estàd que le jour
où le suprême l' de commandaire du NATO
de l'OTAN sera un général européen, là
je pense qu'on aura fait un grand un
grand on aura fait un grand pas. Et
voilà, mais c'est ça qui doit être
l'objectif. Et donc c'est ce qui veut
dire aussi c'est qu'une armée européenne
même si c'est difficile c'est possible
ça existe.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de
la doctrine militaire chinoise ?
Alors
euh d'abord
avant ça, il faudrait mais bon je pense
qu'il faudra Je suis pas du tout
spécialiste de la Chine donc je vais
vous dire un peu ce que monite
non
les Chinois leur priorité c'est
d'assurer
leur leur statut de puissance régionale
pour l'instant dans leur région donc
c'est tout le développement de la marine
en en particul la marine chinoise dans
pour les les dans le le Pacifique et
cetera. Donc c'est ça. Alors je moi je
crois je crois pas du tout je ne pense
pas que la Chine est vocation à devenir
à devenir
une puissance impériale comme nous
l'imag comme nous l'imaginons, comme
nous l'avons toujours connu et cetera.
Je pense que c'est qu'elle devienne une
puissance économique de premier plan,
qu'elle devienne la puissance régionale,
ça oui, qu'elle étende euh je pense
qu'elle est plus à étendre son euh son
impérium euh par des moyens plus softs
euh que la guerre et que l'affrontement
que l'affrontement, c'est voilà. Donc je
je vois pas du tout euh je crois pas du
tout
sauf la prophétie autoréalisatrice
américaine, c'est-à-dire que l'ennemi
c'est la Chine. Donc à force de dire
l'ennemi c'est la Chine, forc ça va
peut-être un jour se réaliser comme ça.
Il y aura vraiment une guerre. Mais je
pense pas que ce soit pour l'instant la
volonté chinoise. Et en tout cas, pour
ce qui concerne le nucléaire, euh les
Chinois
ont toujours dit qu'ils étaient pour le
désarmement nucléaire. Les Chinois ont
autant sinon peut-être moins de bombes
nucléaires que nous, enfin d'ogives
nucléaires que nous. Pour ce que l'on en
sait, hein, bien sûr. Les Chinois ont
toujours dit no first use, c'està-dire
pas d'usage en premier. ce que la France
ne veut pas, ce que les États-Unis ne
veulent pas. Donc au plan de la doctrine
nucléaire, les Chinois sont beaucoup
plus modéré que les Français.
Voilà. Alors, c'est vrai que il
développe
il développe des systèmes d'armes, il
développent des infrastructures, des
missiles et cetera et que il y a une
c'est ça le problème de la Chine, on le
voit d'ailleurs avec le coronavirus,
c'est l'opacité du régime. C'est qu'on
sait pas réellement ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur.
On va vite le savoir. Maintenant, c'est
arrivé chez nous,
on va vite comprendre.
Oui, d'accord. Mais mais en ce qui
concerne le les le domaine militaire, on
sait pas très bien où ils en sont. Ce
qu'on sait, il y a quand même les
chiffres. Alors même pouvoir d'achat, il
faut compenser avec le pouvoir d'achat,
mais le budget militaire euh chinois,
c'est autour de 200 milliards. Alors de
dollars d'euros de dollars. Vous vous
connaissez le budget annuel militaire
américain ?
C'est 5000. Non de combien ? 700
milliards
700 milliards
700 milliards donc ils font trois fois
plus que les Chinois. Alors je dis il y
a évidemment le pouvoir d'achat qui qui
compense un peu mais bon ils sont les
Américains sont largement au-dessus des
Chinois en matière de budget donc de
capacité
et c'est la même chose pour la Russie.
Le budget de la Russie, c'est je sais
plus mais je crois que c'est autour de
80 milliards de dollars. C'est c'est
ridicule par rapport au budget
américain.
Euh une autre question internet. Est-ce
que vous pensez que l'arme de dissuasion
nucléaire française face à au nouveaux
conflits, c'est comme avoir un bazooka
pour chasser le moustique ?
Écoutez,
oui, c'est le marteau pilon pour écraser
une mouche. On pourrait pourrait
continuer comme ça avec plusieurs
exemple. Métaphore, imagaire
n'a plus de pertinence stratégique pour
répondre à ces à ces conflits tels que
nous les connaissons. On voit pas
pourquoi on va que on utiliserait une
arme nucléaire. Sauf, mais je l'ai
entendu,
sauf quelques-uns, on revient à la
frappe chirurgicale, sauf j'ai entendu
un des grands chefs militaire français
dire "Ah oui, mais on pourrait peut-être
lancer une bombe nucléaire, il parlait
de la Syrie dans le désert, ça ferait
peur." Voilà, donc à part de tuer
quelques chameaux, je sais pas à qui ça
ferait peur et puis bon, je suis pas sûr
que ça s'arrêterait là. Donc voilà. Donc
on voit pas l'utilisation d'armes ce
général là.
Euh, il ne le plus,
il ne l' plus. Mais il y a de bon il y a
d'autres déclarations et donc voilà.
Donc non, moi je pense que c'est c'est
bien le fond du problème, c'est qu'il
n'y a plus de d'intérêt stratégique au
mais c'est une arme du passé. C'est une
arme voilà, c'est un héritage de du
passé que bon auquel on s'accroche. Moi
je compare toujours ça à notre ligne
magino. C'est notre ligne magino
nuucléaire.
Dormez brave gens, vous êtes vous êtes
en paix. Voilà, vous pouvez être
tranquille avec la conséquence
euh qui est quand même assez
dommageable, c'est que du coup on
démobilise l'opinion publique en leur
disant "Écoutez, vous fatiguez pas,
votre sécurité est assurée, garantie
absolue de sécurité." Donc bon, écoutez,
pourquoi vous inquiéter ? Pourquoi vous
préoccupez de ces questions ? Il y a eu
un sondage récemment
fait par des universitaires dans tous
les pays européens, enfin dans les pays
européens qui ont des armes nucléaire
sur leur sol et ils ont demandé bon que
pour vous est-ce que vous connaissez le
nombre d'armes nucléaires et cetera et
cetera que qu'est-ce que c'est l'arme
nucléaire pour vous ? C'est la c'est le
c'est ce sont les Français qui ont les
qui qui en savent le moins
qui en savent le moins. C'est eux qui
qui se on leur parle du ils savent pas
combien on a d'armes, à quoi ça sert que
dans quel condition combien ça coûte à
force combien ça coûte savent pas.
Donc c'est c'est tout à fait
symptomatique de cette désinformation ou
non information plutôt du de l'opinion
publique, du public d'une façon général
qui est quand même assez directement
concerné.
Euh je regarde les questions internet.
OK.
OK. Donc là là il y a il y a il y a
beaucoup de questions de de certains sur
un rapport cométa.
Et alors le rapport cométais.
Oui. Oui.
Quand j'étais directeur de l'INN
Institut des hautes études de défense
nationale,
j'ai un ami général de l'armée de l'air
d'ailleurs un pilote de chasse qui est
venu me voir et qui m'a dit "Voilà, je
voudrais faire un rapport, une étude sur
les les ovnis. Tout le monde sait ce que
c'est qu'un ovni et un objet volant non
identifié." Et voilà. Donc
qui n'est pas forcément extraterrestre.
Qui n'est pas forcément extraterrestre.
Exactement. Et donc il m'a dit voilà
mais le problème c'est que on sait pas
où aller. On a besoin d'un peu d'un
espèce de parrainage.
Alors je dis bon est-ce que tu as
d'abord le ton comité d'étude ? Est-ce
que ce sont des gens sérieux ? Il m'a
dit oui il y a un tel un tel ils sont au
kn donc c'était des gens sérieux. Je dis
pas de problème. Moi je par je suis
parti du principe que à partir de quand
il y a un phénomène qu'on explique pas,
il y a des phénomènes qui ont été
étudiés
et il a été prouvé que il y avait pas
d'explication rationnelle connu.
Trace radar.
Voilà exactement et des bris de de des
bris de satellite et cetera qui
retombent. Donc bon, ça méritait qu'on
s'y intéresse. Donc j'ai dit Banco, vous
pz tu peux y aller. Donc ils ont fait
leur étude et ils ont fait un rapport
qui s'appelle le rapport cométa que j'ai
préfacé. Et donc ce rapport a été très
largement diffusé et c'est très étonnant
de voir que le sujet OVNI suscite
beaucoup toujours beaucoup de d'intérêt
voire de passion. Donc les donc il y a
eu beaucoup de questions et j'ai été
très souvent interviewé alors que
c'était pas moi vraiment qui était
concerné. était très souvent concerné
par euh par des questions, par des
personnes qui étaient très intéressées
et qui voulaient voulit en savoir à plus
et cetera et cetera. Voilà donc le
explication du rapport comme état
d'où d' vous vous votre point de vue
c'était en tant que général je veux
savoir ce qui pénètre mon espace aérien
que ça vienne d'ici ou d'ailleurs, je
veux savoir ce qui se passe.
C'était votre démarche ?
Oui. Non, c'est votre démarche pas
simplement celle-là. c'était de dire
quand un phénomène n'est pas expliqué
rationnellement, bon ça mérite qu'on s'y
intéresse, qu'on essaie de voilà de mais
mais comme j'étais avant d'être
commandant de l'aviation de chasse,
j'étais commandant de la défense
aérienne et donc c'était eff le le grand
sujet
et c'était de détecter tout ce qui se
passait dans l'espace. Or, on avait pas
les moyens, on avait pas les les radars
qu'il falaient pour au-delà d'une
certaine altitude pour d'aller dans les
dans au-delà de l'atmosphère.
Et donc, il y a eu tout un lancement de
programme qui a abouti depuis de
lancement de radars pour essayer de voir
parce qu'on dépendait complètement des
États-Unis. Nous à l'époque, on faisait
dans le centre d'opération de la défense
aérienne, on faisait un un état des de
tous les satellites qui et de tout ce
qui évidemment pouvait euh qui pouvait
apparaître dans l'espace qui était pas
et ça c'était des informations données
par les Américains. On était
complètement dépendant des Américains.
Donc depuis on a développé des moyens
pour justement avoir notre propre
analyse de l'espace et notre propre
protection. Quand vous étiez commandant
de la défense aérienne, vous avez vu des
choses rentrer ? Vous saviez pas ce que
c'était ?
Euh
une une fois, mais après on l'a dit
identifié. Oui.
C les Américains qui se baladaient chez
nous.
Non, pas du tout. C'était un morceau de
satellite russe ou de deuxè étage de de
fusé russe qui retombait. Mais ça ça a
traversé tout l' de la France et alors
il y a eu des dizaines et dizaines de
coups de téléphone pour savoir ce que
c'était. Et donc on l'a identifié mais
bon il y a il y a pas que ça hein comme
tu peux rentrer dans dans l'espace.
Il y a quoi d'autre ?
Bah il y a des avions des avions non
identifiés. Bon, moi j'ai j'ai une
anecdote très amusante parce que là,
c'était quand j'étais au cabinet
militaire du Premier ministre et le
comme vous le savez le premier ministre
et lui en charge de la défense, c'est
lui qui et un jour on m'appelle au
téléphone, on me dit il y a un avion qui
a décollé de c au moment de la guerre
froide qui a décollé de Pologne et qui
se dirige
vers chez nous. Donc branle bas de
combat, l'OTAN et cetera. L'OTAN fait
décoller des avions intercepteurs et au
stupeur qu'est-ce qu'il voit ? Ben, il
voit qu'il y a pas de pilote dans
l'avion. C'était un avion. Le pilote
s'était éjecté au décollage de Pologne
et l'avion tout seul m'a monté à je sais
plus combien 10000 m 8000 m et a pris le
cap vers l'ouest. Cap 240 exactement
pour les puristes. Et donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? Est-ce que Bon alors
d'abord les Américains nous disent
est-ce qu'on peut continuer à le suivre
? Souveraineté française, on dit non
c'est notre c'est notre boulot. Et mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Bon on fait
décoller la chasse mais le temps qu'il
arrive c'était audessus de la il devait
arriver audess de l'agglomération
lilloise. Est-ce qu'on la bat ? Mais si
on l'abat il va où est-ce qu'il va
tomber ? Est-ce qu'on le laisse
continuer ? Mais à court desessens, il
va tomber un jour ou l'autre. Et Dieu
enfin Dieu merci pas pour les Belges, il
est tombé à la frontière belge dans la
forêt donc on était sauvé. Donc il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se passe des
ballons dirigeables qui se qui se
baladent. Enfin, il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de
Quand vous voyez le les black jack, les
avions russes, les bombardiers russes
qui ressemblent à des grands machins
blancs se balader aux frontières de la
France,
de l'espace aérien français. C'est quoi
? C'est votre interprétation ? C'est un
concours ? C'est je montre que je suis
là. Oui, c'est de la provocation. Enfin,
un peu de la provocation, c'est montré
Ouais, exactement. C'est montrer que que
qu'on est là, qu'ils sont là, qu'ils
sont actifs, euh qu'ils sont
opérationnels et voilà et qui donc il
faut tenir compte d'eux de leur présence
et puis de le Mais bon, pendant toute la
guerre froide, on a fait ce on a joué à
ce petit jeu donc ça recommence.
C'est dangereux ça, non ? Quand on voit
par exemple
au bout du compte Oui, parce que le
problème c'est que euh bon parce que
bien sûr personne enfin au moins les
avion russes, ils mettent pas leur leur
moyens d'identification, ce qu'on
appelle l'IFF en particulier. Il y en a
d'autres mais il y a celui-là le plus
connu qui et donc voilà tout peut
arriver parce qu'on sait tout peut
arriver, on sait pas. D'abord, il peut y
avoir des collisions avec des avions
civils, hein. C'est comme un peu comme
enfin surtout on on connaît pas
réellement leurs intentions.
Quand on voit quand on voit le récemment
le l'avion du ministre des affaires du
ministre de la défense russe
se fait approcher d'une façon
ostentatoire par un avion de l'OTAN en
mer Baltique.
Son escorte montre le ventre. Vous savez
ce que ça veut dire quand on monte son
ventre. Est-ce que c'est aussi une
provocation ? C'estàd qu'on a les
capacités de voir qui c'est depuis très
loin, mais on fait quand même approcher
un avion pour une identification
visuelle.
Toujours.
Ouais. Mais c'est-à-dire que bon, je
sais pas exactement quelle était la
trajectoire de de cet avion. Est-ce
qu'il est rentré dans l'espace aérien
Balte ou ou norvégien ? Je sais pas.
Mais comme on a depuis plusieurs années,
on a maintenant une permanence de
défense aérienne assurée par les pays de
de l'OTAN alternativement et y compris
par la France de donc ça veut dire quoi
? Des avions en alerte qui sont qui sont
là pour intercepter des des avions bon
des avions russes hein je
essentiellement. Donc euh bon voilà,
c'est la procédure normale. La prosure
c'est pas de monter pas de montrer le
ventre, c'est d'abord l'identification
visuelle
et c'estàdire que
le signe amical c'est de battre des
plans, c'est de battre des ailes pour
montrer et cetera et donc
l'interrogation à la radio et puis
ensuite ensuite il y a toute une
gradation dans les mesures dans c'est
c'est codé hein en particulier c'est
c'est des c'est des procédures au temps
qui sont appliquées dans tous les pays a
toute une toute une gradation dans
simplement l'inspection visuelle,
l'interrogation et ensuite si vraiment
il y a pas de réponse, ensuite il y a
des mesures d'intimidation qui peuvent
aller même jusqu'à des tirs de semence
des tirs de semence à côté de l'avion
pas voilà si si l'avion n'obéit pas.
Donc, mais ça c'est ce sont des
procédures euh normales.
Quand on voit un avion civil escorter de
de deux intercepteurs
chargé à la gueule, permettez-moi
l'expression, et qu'on laisse quand même
son F18 à côté accompagné, est-ce que ça
peut être interprété comme une menace et
est-ce que ça peut déclencher tout un
tas de de choses ?
Mais c'est vous, vous vous avez raison,
c'était vous savez c'est le problème de
la réaction en chaîne. Non, c'est pour
montrer qu'on est là. Mais bon, je
montre qu'on est là. Si vous savez, je
suis le plus fort. Je montre mes
pectoriser à être vulgaire pour vous.
Est-ce que c'est pas un concours de bit
qui va nous échapper ?
C'est un concours de de d'école dans les
cours de cours de récré un peu, c'est
tout hein. Donc voilà, je suis le plus
fort, je suis là et cetera et cetera.
Donc le problème c'est que bon, il y a
des procédures normales. C'est normal
qu'on a identifié quand il y a un avion
qui rentre dans votre espace aérien et
qui et qu'il est pas identifié qui et
qui ne qui ne répond pas à la radio.
Bon, c'est normal qu'on aille c'est à
titre de précaution, enfin c'est c'est
le travail de la défense aérienne
d'aller voir ce qui est l'identifier et
cetera et cetera.
Mais bon, mais quand on joue à un petit
jeu comme ça où je suis là, tu es là,
oui, mais moi je suis le plus fort et
cetera, bon ça ça peut dégénérer. Il y a
eu un rapport qui a été fait par une ONG
britannique qui s'appelle European
Leadership Network qui a qui a fait un
rapport très intéressant qui d'abord qui
a répertorié le nombre d'incidents de ce
type qu'il a eu ces dernières années et
qui montre que bon voilà qu' qu'il est
croissant et bon mais que ça peut
dériver dangereusement.
Question d'internet. Que pensent-il des
exercices de l'OTAN en Europe ? 37000
hommes cette année dont 20000 Américains
?
Ben c'est c'est toujours pareil. C'est
c'est exactement le même le même
engrenage. C'estd que c'est une
démonstration de force pour montrer que
que il y a une mobilisation de l'OTAN
donc américaine pour protéger les pays
de d'Europe centrale. Et donc les les
les Russes pardon font la même chose de
l'autre côté de leur frontière.
Donc ils font des exercices de la même
manière. Donc voilà c'est toujours un
jeu un peu dangereux. Donc c'est pour ça
que bon, il faut essayer de limiter
cette espèce de de démonstration de
force mutuelle qui bon qui peut bon ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas des
exercices, qu'il faut pas démontrer la
solidarité
entre les pays européens mais bon voilà
il faut aussi savoir raison garder.
Comment on fait pour armer la population
civile contre ça contre ces concours de
qui a la plus grosse ?
On fait quoi pour toucher la la société
civile ?
Alors, c'est plus facile de faire
l'inverse, c'est de les de d'exacerber
les sentiments un peu comme ça que de
faire l'inverse. Bon, mais c'est
l'information et puis c'est essayer de
de dialoguer.
Alors bon, c'est un bien grand mot, mais
essayer d'avoir des échanges avec la
partie entre guillemets adverse.
qui comme c'est le cas en ce moment tout
ce qui constituait l'architecture un peu
de la sécurité européenne, c'est-à-dire
tous les tous les accords qu'il y
avaient qui établissaient
des des liens et des contraintes entre
les États.
Je parle, je vais pas chercher bien
loin, il s'agit de l'Europe, hein. Bon,
tout ça a volé en éclat en train de vol
est en train de voler en éclat. En ce
moment, il ne reste plus que le traité
new start qui a été signé par Obama et
Poutine qui limitait le nombre de de de
d'armes nucléaires pour les les
États-Unis et la Russie. Il reste plus
que cet accord qui qui
vient qui se termine en en 2021. Ça veut
dire que si l'année prochaine ce traité
new start d'une façon ou d'une autre
n'est pas renouvelé, il n'y aura plus
d'accord de sécurité et l'Europe va
redevenir le champ de bataille nucléaire
futur. pas compliqué parce que là déjà
on alors qu'il y avait un traité
d'interdiction
des missiles intermédiaires c'est en
gros c'était le traité INF qui a été
dénoncé par
Trump
et qui en gros empêcha
les les Russes et l'OTAN de développer
et d'avoir des missiles qui dont la
portée forcément les contraigners à
tomber en Europe donc que ce soit le la
Russie européenne ou ou l'Europe
occidentale. Donc voilà, et ce traité
n'existe plus. Donc les deux pays, les
États-Unis, la Russie et les autres pays
aussi comme la France, on développe des
missiles à porté intermédiaire. Donc
c'est moins de 5500 km. Donc c'est en
gros des missiles de 500 même de 500 km.
Voilà. Euh qui sont bon 500 km pour ne
rien vous cacher, c'est le c'est
l'Europe hein. C'est l'Europe le premier
le prochain champ de bataille nucléaire
si on continue comme ça.
Joyeux question d'internet. Euh 4e essai
de Totof, on t'a vu c'est pas besoin pas
besoin d'écrire en majuscule. Monsieur
Norlin pense-t-il que la France sera
capable de maintenir sa légitimité
nucléaire avec les années ?
Avec les années ?
Ouais.
Ah oui, malheureusement oui. Là on est
en train Malheureusement oui parce que
là on est en train de de voter enfin
c'est voté une modernisation mais c'est
plus qu'une modernisation un
renouvellement de nos systèmes, de nos
sous-marins, de nos avions et des
missiles qui qui sont équip qui équipent
nos avions. Les missiles nucléaires bien
sûr
pour ça va durer jusqu'en 2080.
Euh on là pour les prochaines années, on
y met quand même 37 milliards d'euros.
Il faut savoir que le coût pour la
France de de l'entretien et du
développement et du renouvellement,
c'est c'était jusqu'à maintenant environ
4 milliards et demi par an, c'est-à-dire
10 % du budget de la défense, 20 % du
budget d'investissement de la défense.
Maintenant, on va passer à 6 à 7
milliards officiellement.
Donc ce sera ça sera plus ce qui veut
dire que ça fera plus de 30 % du budget
d'investissement. Bon le budget de la
défense a beau augmenté,
il est pas extensible. Bon ça veut dire
que qu'est-ce qui va en souffrir ? Ben,
ce sont les forces qui sont actuellement
sur le terrain, qui manquent
d'équipement, qui ont des hélicoptères
qui don pour lesquels qui ne peuvent pas
voler parce qu'il y a pas de pièces de
de remplacement
parce que les matériels suusent, les
blindés sent, le sable et cetera. Et bon
et c'est quand même eux qui sont en
train de de faire des opérations
réelles, donc qui risquent leur vie et
ça se fait au au détriment euh euh au
moins en grande partie au détriment des
forces conventionnelles.
On est toujours à ciré pneu desvabes le
14 juillet pour faire beau.
C'est normal que pour le 14 juillet, on
montre des équipements qui qui soient
beau. Alors si je sais pas, moi j'ai
jamais vu ça puisque j'étais dans un
avion ou à pied.
Et donc non, je pense que on en est pas
là mais on manque, c'est vrai que les
forces conventionnelles françaises et
bon manque beaucoup de d'équipements de
toutes sortes. Non seulement de système
d'armes mais aussi d'équipement tout
court. Trop souvent les soldats, les
militaires français sont occupés sont
obligés pardon de de s'acheter eux-mêmes
leurs équipements personnels. Voilà donc
ça voilà et tout ça va va se faire. tout
ce tout cet argent qu'on va mettre dans
des forces nucléaires. Alors que pour
les maintenir, bon, il suffit euh il
suffirait euh de les maintenir en état.
On n' pas besoin de changer de
génération de sous-marins tous les 10
ans he ou tous les 20 ans. Donc on peut
les on peut faire durer plus longtemps
les sous-marins, ils seront tout aussi
opérationnels. Ils auront toujours la
même efficacité opérationnelle. Donc
réponse à la question oui, la France a
les moyens. Bon peu en tout cas. Autre
question. Euh, on fait quoi quand un
seul satellite de surveillance russe
vient saluer le nôtre ? Virgule on
envoie les rafales pour interrogation.
Non, les rafales malheureusement
n'iraient pas aussi haut. N'iront
n'iront pas aussi haut. Non, c'est c'est
ce qu'on a fait. C'estàd qu'on a on
vient de créer un commandement spatial
euh et on vient de de on essaie de
développer des systèmes euh alors
défensifs offensifs euh pour justement
protéger nos nos satellites parce que
nos satellites de renseignement de
localisation sont effectivement le là
pour le coup c'est la clé de voûte de
des opérations. Si on n plus ces
renseignements et ben on peut plus rien
faire.
Alors, autre question d'internet.
Y a-t-il un risque Y a-t-il un risque à
une démilitarisation profonde ?
On n'est pas parti pour ça. Je pense pas
que ce soit le risque actuel en ce
moment. On est alors on est peut-être
qu'il y a une autre facette à cette
question. Euh pour le moment, on est
parti dans une course aux armements
frénétiques euh dans tous les domaines.
Maintenant euh est-ce que euh les
opinions publiques ne sont-elles pas euh
entre guillemets démilitarisées ? C'est
vrai que le fait de dire que on est à
l'abri du parapluie nucléaire, qu'on n
pas se soucier de ces aspect là, bon
après tout, il y a certainement un
désintérêt
un désintérêt pour la chose militaire,
même si quand même tout le monde se rend
compte que la situation internationale
devient de plus en plus tendue et
conflictuelle,
je pense quand même qu'il y a une
certaine désaffection pour les choses
militaires. Bon, il y a plus il n'y a
plus le service militaire en plus. Les
hommes politiques, c'est une génération
qui n'a pas fait qui ne connaît rien à
l'armée aux choses qui connu la guerre
qui n'a pas connu la guerre. Donc c'est
c'est vrai que de de ce côté-là, oui, il
y a une certaine démilitarisation. C'est
un des grands soucis d'ailleurs des des
forces armées, hein, de de maintenir le
contact de maintenir le contact et de
montrer la nécessité d'une défense.
Question internet. sans dissuasion
nucléaire virgule la France ne
devra-t-elle pas établir une autre forme
de démonstration de puissance exposant
plus nos soldats virgule c'est jouable
politiquement.
Euh alors d'abord je pense que
donc moi je pense pas qu' qu'il faille
supprimer les armes nucléaires
françaises immédiatement. Donc c'est
tout ça c'est une opération dans le
temps long. Mais mais bon ça veut dire
que ça veut dire effectivement qu'il
faut repenser notre action.
dit conventionnel, mais quand je dis
conventionnel, c'est aussi le
dérèglement climatique, c'est aussi ce
qu'on a dit le les hackurs, le
cyberdéfense, c'est aussi il y a plein
de domaines.
Donc voilà, donc j'ai perdu le fil de la
question là.
Je recommence la question. Sans
dissuasion nucléaire, la France ne
devra-t-elle pas établir une autre forme
de démonstration de puissance exposant
plus nos soldats virgule c'est jouable
politiquement ? Non, au contraire, ça
per Non, là les nos soldats sont déjà
exposés donc elles sont déjà exposés sur
le terrain et bon et je ne pense pas et
là on ne peut on peut pas faire plus.
L'avantage de consacrer plus de plus de
de moyens de donner plus de moyens aux
forces conventionnelles, c'est de
permettre d'avoir d'élargir
notre palette d'action et surtout de la
rendre plus efficace, plus sûre, moins
dépendante de des apports américains et
cetera. Mais je pense pas que ça
entraînerait un accroissement de des
risques humains, de pertes humaines.
Nos capacités de projection, c'est
combien de milliers de kilomètres ? 3000
km.
Oui, je pense que le c'est calculé. Oui.
Sur 3000 4000 km. Bon, c'est ce que là
en ce moment, c'est ce qui se passe à
Barcane dans le Sahel, à peu près de cet
ordre de grandeur. Mais bon, maintenant,
bon, en théorie, c'est illimité.
Maintenant, je si on regarde simplement
les les forces aériennes avec le
ravitaillement en vol, vous pouvez
opérer dans n'importe quel coin du monde
en quelques heures, hein, et avec le
ravitaillement vol, donc sans escale.
Euh bon, voilà, donc il y a il y a une
capacité il y a il y a une capacité
d'intervention très lointaine qui est
qui fait partie des nouveaux aspects
justement de de de des opérations.
La Libye, c'était bien, c'était pas
bien.
Bon, je crois que quand les opérations
en Libye, quand on a déclenché nous, la
France et l'Angleterre, les opérations
en Libye, je pense que tout le monde
peut-être était victime euh était
victime des affiches. Tout le monde
pensait que c'était une bonne chose.
Bon, la longue, on se rend bien compte
que
Qu'est-ce que vous c'est quoi les
affiches ? Ben, les affiches c'était
Kaddafi, c'est c'était l'action
humanitaire,
c'était Kaddafi est un monstre qui tue
ses propres populations, qui les
torture, qui était qui était qui était
vrai en partie au moins en grande
partie. Mais voilà, on a ajouté du
désordre au désordre et peut-être encore
plus de désordre que le désordre qu'il y
avait avant.
Donc voilà, je pense que les à la
réflexion,
je pense que c'est c'était effectivement
une erreur.
La guerre, c'est l'extension de la
politique, non ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Est-ce que vous trouvez pas que
maintenant nos armées sont devenues les
femmes de ménage de de politiciens
inconséquent ?
voir un continent
euh c'est bon toutes les manières euh
non je crois c'est c'est pas tellement
ça c'est pas tellement ça le la question
la question c'est
que les aspects politiques
deviennent de plus en plus prépondérant
et je prends un exemple concret
ce que nous faisons à Barca au Sahel
l'opération Barcane au Sahel bon on voit
bien qu'on essaie de faire. Oui, ce que
mais ce qu'on fait aussi, on fait des
fait combien
5000 soldats sur combien de milliers de
kilomètres ? comme l'Europe à peu près
avec des avec du matériel défectueux et
tout ce qu'on oui oui. Non mais ce qu'on
fait bon voilà c'est c'est
c'est quand même c'est quand même bien.
Mais là aussi j'ai perdu le fil de la
votre question là parce que
Arcane
Oui mais non mais oui mais Barcane c'est
Ouais c'est une une bonne chose.
C'est-à-dire que en terme de voilà ce
que je voulais dire c'est que c'est les
opérations sont complexes. C'est-à-dire
qu'on se rend bien compte que la
solution ne peut pas être qu'une
solution militaire.
Donc la solution elle est politique,
elle est économique, elle est
culturelle, tout ce qu'on voudra. Donc
voilà, c'est un ensemble et bon toutes
maintenant tous les conflits dans
lesquels, bon c'est pas nouveau hein,
euh ça remonte au calandre grec mais euh
quand même on voit bien que toutes les
toutes les opérations sont de plus en
plus complexes. C'est le cas de
l'Afghanistan de la même manière de
Syrie, de l'Irak et cetera. C'est que et
que là-dedans l'aspect politique compte
énormément.
de deux trois dernières questions. Quand
on vend du matériel militaire à l'Arabie
Saoudite,
ça vous fait quoi vous en tant que
militaire ?
Bon, si vous voulez, d'un côté c'est une
excellente opération pour les
l'industrie d'armement et
je pense qu'on a besoin d'une industrie
d'armement contrairement à beaucoup
mais effectivement quand on voit que ces
armements servent au Yémen forcément he
puisqu'on vend des armements même si
dans le langage diplomatique on dit ce
sont des armements défensifs on voit
bien que ces armements sont utilisés sur
des théâtres d'opération dans lesquels
on n pas forcément envie de se trouver
mêlé. Bon voilà, ça pose des problèmes.
Donc c'est tout le problème des
exportations d'armement qui sont
nécessaires pour l'industrie mais aussi
qui pose donc en France c'est quand même
assez bien fait. Il y a une commission
d'exportation
mais voilà il y a il y a quand même ça
c'est business
business. Il y a quand même une décision
qui est politique au bout du compte
quand même qui est à prendre.
Votre plus beau souvenir dans un avion
c'était dans quoi et à quelle altitude ?
D'abord euh
la dernière fois que vous avez tenu à
manche, c'était quand ?
Euh ben quand j'ai quitté le dernier
jour de où j'ai quitté l'armée de l'air,
c'est-à-dire il y a maintenant ça fait
un certain temps hein. Donc cé en 1996,
j'étais sur un vol sur Mirage de 1000.
C'était mon dernier jour dans l'armée de
l'air et c'était vraiment très émouvant.
Non, euh euh un deux souvenirs, un très
fort puisque je me suis éjecté euh d'un
Mirage et fin euh
le fameux
donc euh bon à la suite d'une panne
réacteur donc euh
classique chez le Mirage et F1. Je sais
pas si mais c'était une c'était une
avarie connue, c'était des vibrations de
la lettre du compresseur. C'était
c'était assez connu. Donc je m'éjecte et
quand même c'est quand même une
expérience assez intéressante. Ou alors
où on se trouve dans la situation
dans laquelle on voit là, je voyais pas
le sol. Vous voyez quand même la couche
de nuage qui était assez basse qui se
rapproche à toute vitesse. On voit
l'altimètre qui dévisse. Vous savez, on
dit parce qu'il tourne dans le sens
inverse, il descend à toute vitesse. Et
là le choix, on est là. Moi, j'avais la
chance bon de pas voir le feu dans
l'avion. Enfin, je voyais pas, il y
avait le feu dans le réacteur mais je
voyais pas. Donc, j'étais très
confortable. Mais quand vous réalisez
que l'avion tombe à toute vitesse, bon
voilà, il va falloir quitter le confort
douillé de la cabine, si je puis dire,
pour l'inconnu. Et donc voilà. Donc ça
c'est quand même un moment très fort.
Ensuite après c'est la petite histoire,
c'est assez drôle et puis un des moments
les les plus beaux que j'ai connu
c'était
c'est des moments de grâce
qu'on appelle nous de la poursuite entre
les nuages. C'estàd que on faisait ça à
deux ou quatre avions. Donc on se met
l'un derrière l'autre et on et on
pourrait plus le faire maintenant à
cause de la densité des espaces aériens.
Et on évolue et là il y avait des nuages
vous savez des cumulus avec des espaces
de ciel bleu et donc comme des des
immeubles immenses et c'est magnifique.
Et là on a joué là-dedans, on était deux
avions et c'était un moment de grâce
extraordinaire. Là là l'aéronautique
c'est quelque chose de formidable.
Vous avez votre propre avion ?
Non non non j'ai Non non
malheureusement. Bon c'est un peu
coûteux hein.
Même pas un petit DR 250 ?
Même pas non même le DR 200 c'est assez
coûteux. Donc j'ai fait quand même pas
mal de ensuite d'avion d'aviation légère
mais bon pour un pilote de chasse c'est
voilà c'est c'est quand même moins
intéressant puis il y a un moment il
faut décrocher
le combien ça gagne en général 5 étoiles
est-ce que vous croyez que je peux vous
le dire oui c'est notre argentou
ça gagne
hors impôt c'estd impôt brut
C'est tout.
Mais non, attendez. Non, retraité hein.
Alors, d'active, je sais pas. Je sais
plus un peu plus.
OK. Est-ce que vous voyez des choses à
aborder avec nous qu'on a pas abordé ?
Oui, sur j'ai pas fini de répondre à
votre question sur l'extension du
parapluie nucléaire à l'Allemagne
parce que c'est très intéressant de de
voir ce que ça recouvre en fait. Bon,
d'abord c'est les Allemands en général
bon ont pas tellement envie de d'avoir
de partager le parapluie nucléaire et
d'abord c'est une vieille proposition
française he vous savez que Alain Jupé
l'avait déjà faite ça s'appelait la
dissuasion concertée alors maintenant on
parle de dissuasion élargie et cetera et
cetera mais surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que c'est une
manière pour les partisans du nucléaire
et c'est pas seulement en France mais
beaucoup en France de comment dirais-je
de diluer leur responsabilité.
C'est-à-dire que avec la sortie de de la
Grande-Bretagne, de l'Europe, on devient
en France le seul pays nucléaire de
l'Europe occidentale continentale.
Donc euh bon, par les temps qui courent,
le nucléaire devient quand même un petit
peu vulnérable compte tenu
du fait que il y a quand même des
mouvements de plus en plus forts qui
contestent l'armure nucléaire. Je vous
rappelle que récemment
est en cours de ratification à l'ONU un
traité d'interdiction des armes
nucléaires qui a été signé au départ par
122 pays. Donc qui n'est pas encore
ratifié, donc il est pas encore mais
bon, il y a une menace sur les sur les
armes nucléaires que il y a une
condamnation du pape très ferme sur
l'aspect immoral et criminel de de
l'arme nucléaire. Et donc il y a une
donc le fait de dire aux Allemands et
aux Européens bon vous allez bénéficier
c'est une manière de leur dire c'est
comme vous savez dans la pièce de
Shakespeare César c'est Brutus qui dit
aux autres conjurés bon maintenant moi
j'ai tué César mais c'est maintenant
vous allez tremper aussi votre votre
dague ou votre poignard dans le sang de
César comme ça vous serez tous concernés
c'est un peu le même le même bon en
toute proportion gardée bien entendu
c'est un peu le même le même concept La
même idée, c'est de dire "OK, maintenant
vous allez tous ensemble, vous allez
participer à notre force de frappe
nucléaire, donc vous allez tous être
impliqués, donc on dilue les
responsabilités et bon voilà et donc
tout le tour est joué."
J'ai une question internet,
je vous la pose comme elle elle m'est
affiché. Général, si tu avais 20 ans en
2020, franchement, tu rentrerais dans
l'armée.
Ah oui, dans l'armée de l'air ? Oui. Ah
oui oui pour être pilote. Oui oui parce
que bon j'ai fait ce métier pendant 36
ans même si j'ai pas été pendant 36 ans
un pilote complètement opérationnel
parce qu'il y a un moment où on est
quand même écarté des unités
opérationnelles et même si on vole
encore sur les avions de combat. Bon
c'est c'est un métier extraordinaire.
Bon il y a il y a tout. à la fois
l'aspect concentration
physique, résistance physique,
intelligence des situations, c'est un
métier et c'est un métier aussi qui est
comme c'est comme un métier d'artisan.
C'est-à-dire que il y a un savoir-faire
manuel, manier un avion, même maintenant
où c'est que c'est quand même des
ordinateurs volants, il y a quand même
l'aspect
l'aspect manipulation de l'avion. Il un
avion ça a une personnalité. Chaque
avion a sa personnalité. Il faut
composer avec, il faut il faut jouer
avec, il faut le connaître et cetera.
C'est comme un artisan qui fait un
meuble, qui fait quelque chose. Il y a
un aspect manuel et puis en même temps,
il y a un aspect extraordinairement de
concentration nerveuse, de concentration
intellectuelle et cetera. Donc c'est
c'est un métier très complet. Et bon,
puis une impression de liberté quand
vous êtes à 30000 pieds, 40000 pieds,
donc 10 15000 m là vous survolez, vous
êtes ailleurs, vous êtes dans un autre
monde.
Est-ce qu'il y a toujours des problèmes
de santé avec les pilotes de chasse qui
se font un petit peu irradiés par leur
radar embarqué ?
Non, jamais connu ça. Euh moi, j'ai eu
j'ai toujours eu des radars sur mes
avions. À ma connaissance, j'ai pas été
radié. Non. Euh les radiations, c'est
quand vous êtes dans un nuage
radioactif, ça oui. Quand vous êtes
exposé à la radioactivité, bon alors
voilà. Bon, vous me direz qu'il y a de
la radioactivité partout, mais dans un
avion, j'ai jamais connu ce problème.
Sauf peut-être pour ceux qui allaient
faire des prélèvement des prélèvements
dans les nuages radioactifs, ça c'est
autre chose.
D'accord. et que quand on a un radar
dans le nez, on se prend pas euh
Bah, il y en a forcément, hein. C'est
mais bon,
jamais cette question n'a été évoquée et
jamais euh bon, j'ai senti des troubles
à ce sujet. Non, non, c'est pas ça ça ça
pas rentré du tout en ligne de compte,
pas du tout.
Mais j'ajoute sur le métier de pilote de
chasse que ce qui lui donne aussi une
espèce de de dimension qui est tragique,
c'est que c'est un métier qui est quand
même très dangereux.
Et donc il y a il y a une autre
dimension qui était un peu tragique,
c'est que c'est bon vous avez 25 ans,
vous êtes de cette avion, c'est votre
vie hein qui est que vous exposez
vraiment tous les jours chaque fois que
vous voulez. Donc c'est c'est vraiment
un métier très particulier.
Est-ce que vous avez des livres à nous
conseiller ? Trois.
Alors ben ça c'est que malheureusement
ça va tourner un peu trop sur le la
bombe. Il y a un livre d'un philosophe
qui est d'ailleurs polytechnicien
français qui s'appelle Jean-Pierre
Dupuit et qui ce livre celui que je
le titre je crois c'est la guerre qui
n'aura pas lieu ou qui n'aurait pas lieu
et c'est aux éditions desclés brè et la
spécialité de Jean-Pierre Dupuit c'est
de c'est de le catastrophisme éclairé ça
veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire qu'il dit
et en particulier à propos de la dissu
nucléaire et à propos de d'un conflit
nucléaire éventuel donc d'une espèce de
de low cost humanitaire. Et donc il dit
il dit bon il faut avoir ça présent à
l'esprit mais il faut il faut l'avoir à
l'esprit pour mieux l'empêcher. Quelque
chose comme ça je qui me pardonne si je
résume aussi mal sa pensée. Il y a un
livre aussi d'un américain type jeune
qui est formidable qui s'appelle Wilson
et qui le titre c'est armes nucléaire et
si elle ne servait à rien parce que ça
aussi c'est parce qu'en général on tête
on traite les tous ceux qui sont opposés
ou celles qui sont opposés aux armes de
clair en disant que ce sont des
utopistes des naïfs. L'expression
favorite du bervérine c'est les
bisounours. Mais moi je réponds très
simplement qui sont les utopistes et les
naïfs ? Est-ce que ce ne sont pas ceux
ou celles qui croient que l'arme nucler
garantit une sécurité totale ? Quand on
dit c'est la garantie totale de absolue
de sécurité, c'est vraiment c'est une
tromperie. Et donc voilà, c'est
complètement c'est complètement faux. Le
le véritable réalisme, c'est de dire
"Oui, il y a un risque de guerre
nucléaire et voilà que il faut il faut
prendre tous les moyens pour
l'empêcher."
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? quelque chose
d'impérissable, une bouteille à la mer.
Oui. Ah oui. Ah oui oui oui. Je leur dis
oui. Absolument. Et donc c'est un des
grands sujets de réflexion de notre
organisation
initiative pour le désarement nucléaire,
c'est d'impliquer les jeunes. Les jeunes
sont très impliqués quand même, Dieu
merci, sur pour le climat et de leur
dire mais attention, le climat, le
dérèglement climatique, le climat,
l'environnement, les menaces, c'est très
lié aux armes nucléaires. D'une part,
parce que tout le monde comprend que
s'il y a une explosion nucléaire, il y
aura des dégâts sur l'environnement, il
y aura des dégâts bien sûr sur
le climat avec l'hiver nucléaire et
cetera et cetera. Mais ce que l'on c'est
c'est mal et ce qu'on c'est que
inversément dans la mesure où il y a où
il y aura des autour des ressources
naturelles, autour de l'immigration,
autour des problèmes de de la question
de l'eau, il y aura forcément des
tensions de plus en plus fortes, des
complis. On rajoute ça une démographie
galopante. Donc il y aura et donc plus
il y aura de d'armes nucléaires dans la
mesure où il y a des armes nucléaires,
donc on va vers des confis nucléaires.
Donc les jeunes, c'est vraiment notre
message leur dire écoutez il faut vous
impliquer dans ces questions. Il faut
prendre conscience de ces de ces
menaces, de ces de ces risques de ces et
donc de ces enjeux de sécurité. Il faut
que c'est vous qui êtes concerné,
c'est vos générations, c'est votre
génération qui est directement impliquée
et donc c'est à vous de prendre cette
ces questions en main.
Mon général, merci.
[Musique]